i want to talk about this blackrock
thing because ben shapiro uh has made
this statement
basically defending blackrock and uh
before we get into specifics of ben
shapiro's statement i'll pull up his
tweet i believe they have it uh
they have it i guess they i guess they
don't have bench appears in this why do
they not
that's like a weird thing to do anyway
but we'll we'll talk about bench press
statement
um i want to point out i just was denied
for a home loan so this was something
i've been working on for the past
several months
and i'll leave the details uh a bit
private for now maybe maybe i'll talk
about it uh once i get more information
from the company that denied
but uh it's been a weird go of things so
i've been to the mortgage process before
i am um very capable of of
getting a mortgage my credit is
fantastic my income is fantastic
and they said no and what i'm learning
now because i tweeted about this is that
they have sent
false credit to my understanding false
credit report information
used to stop me from being able to get a
loan in the house
it all seems very strange it was it's
been i think three months
of agents being swapped around demanding
the same documents over and over and
over again maybe like six or seven times
and then when we do a new person pops up
and says hey i'm the agent now now you
gotta send it again
it really feels like they're trying to
stop us there was a point where i was
like are we gonna cancel this
because they are this is insane why
won't they just say no
no that they're really trying to sludge
us up so we can't buy
at the same time you have this viral
story about a company called blackrock
as well
as a bunch of other investment firms
that are buying up houses paying 20 to
50
above market i had a bunch of people
tweeting at me in response to this
thread
where they're saying things like one guy
says you know i wanted to buy a house
that was 300k
i had more than enough money in the bank
for a decent down payment and
uh and closing costs and then an
investment company came in and bid
20 000 above my offer and i countered
and they put another 20. i just couldn't
compete with them
so this is the kind of thing that's been
happening shutting out people
from being able to buy homes now full
disclosure i
uh i'm fine without a lender i just
thought it was irresponsible you know
there's other things i'd like to invest
in particularly hiring journalists and
running a company and putting it back
into this
operation um but you know uh
i guess uh for regular working-class
people
they're not gonna have these advantages
or these opportunities and i think
i was kind of shocked because uh you
know i did not
i did not see this coming to be you know
swatted down so we
so i want to i want to get into with
that being said the point the reason i
bring that up is just to express
my feeling of unease weariness confusion
and it just
feels really weird at the same time i'm
having this
absurd difficulty getting a house i'm
seeing these stories from
vox and from mediaite for business
insider don't buy a house it's a bubble
you don't want to own property
no no no it's a bad idea millennials
regret it yeah
it's interesting it's it's really it's a
really amazing thing i mean owning a
house is fantastic
your costs are cheaper per month than
renting yet they're telling people not
to do it
so when they say it's a bubble that
means if you buy a 500
the argument is if you buy a 500 000
house now in a year it's going to be
worth 350
000 and you're going to have a loan on
it that's cost more than the value
yes so you can't sell yours but if you
buy it at face value it's going to be
worth less but it doesn't really matter
because you already own the property
i just really don't think that uh
blackrock and these other firms
putting in 50 above market expect to
lose that money i think they're going to
try and flip it i would imagine they're
going to they're going to ride the
inflation and then sell it
and and make money off it or start
renting or just rent it out no they're
turning them into
they're they're converting a bunch of
these into single family rentals so
we're we're dangerously close to the
point where these large
international investment funds own all
the property
the property value skyrockets you can't
buy it and then you become what's called
a vassal do you know what a vassal is
i am famous when the feudal lord would
say in exchange for this
grant of land to you you provide the
landlord with some kind of
you know service or function but at that
point only the landlord would be the
vassal
of the the lord you of the king you
would be the surf
of the vassal you wouldn't even have
vassalage status
i i think one of the one of the bad
things about this is how
not just that this is bad what they're
doing but that i think a lot of people
would find this to be ideal right
i mean we're looking we're looking at a
time
we're looking at a time where a lot of
people are acting like moan ads
right they're individual units well
we're looking at the
we're looking at the breakup of
different things if we see what happened
during kovid during the during the riots
right communities were attacked
right we're looking right now at attacks
on different parts of america
different parts of the country
desecration of our symbols desecration
of our history
it's like if people if you're telling
people
you shouldn't have families your
communities are bad
your communities are stupid your
communities are racist
if that's how you're attacking them
right there then aren't people gonna say
like yeah well
i don't know why do i want to own a home
and help build this community and people
are telling me
that having a community like this is bad
that it's racist it's dumb it's vulgar
it's
it's whatever why do i want to do this i
think there's a there's a real risk too
if you get a house in the wrong area
someone's going to come and smash it up
and then you're screwed that's a
terrible thing but
let me show you what ben shapiro said so
ben shapiro engaged in this story from
the wall street journal
saying i see many people are enraged at
blackrock
blackrock is buying homes from people
willing to sell them if you don't like
what they're doing target the loose
governmental policy incentivizing this
sort of investment
seriously blackrock isn't going to stop
investing in single-family homes because
you're mad on twitter
but you could direct your energies
towards stopping the fed's insane
monetary policy which is driving down
the cost of loans
and creating a massive bubble if
blackrock is willing to take the risk of
leveraging up
to buy single-family housing at above
market prices
that's their prerogative so long as they
own the downside risk no bailouts ever
and if you're mad at blackrock and want
to artificially prevent them from buying
single-family homes
i'd like for you to explain to those who
currently own the homes
why you're taking money out of their
pockets
so uh i'm my first response to to ben's
tweet with respect
would be i wonder what his opinion is on
chinese nationals buying up homes from
people above market
what's the difference between between
international investment firms who are
taking away
because of their ability to get access
to fed you know federal
federally printed money from the fed
federal reserve they're artificially
able to to out-compete the middle class
taking away the middle class opportunity
for home ownership but what about china
i mean if someone comes to me and says
you know a chinese national wants to uh
wants to buy my house for above market i
mean i'm going to say no
i'm going to say i don't feel
comfortable selling to foreign interests
at a time
when the middle class in the working
class in my own country is hurting if we
actually in this nation had scruples
then people who own the homes might be
like i am not going to sell to this
massive investment firm in fact i've
talked to people
who have told me they were selling and
they were saying that they're going to
make sure it doesn't go
to any one of these big corporations for
above market and they only want to sell
to american working families well we
used to make movies about this right
this is the kind of thing that used to
be the heart of american
of american popular culture right you
you made
you made movies about what it's like to
have a community what it's like to have
this is essentially what it's a
wonderful life is about right
why is uh why is it a great town because
george bailey stuck around
and he allowed them all to he he allowed
the the working classes to build a home
when it became pottersville it was this
horrible vulgar
town prostitution and gambling and stuff
like that that's an important thing
and what's weird is how many how many
people
i'm not going to say on the right but
how many americans generally how many
american
thought leaders intellectuals have
missed what's been going on over the
last four years
how some of these arguments have shifted
right do we want
do we want a market do we want a country
what does it take to have a country what
does it take to build communities
and if you're just going to talk about
markets then you're not going to have
communities and you're not going to have
a country
that's a good point man i don't like
using the heavy hand of the law unless i
unless you know after great debate maybe
we do but
maybe it should be illegal to freeze
firms and investment firms to buy
property if there's another
a human trying to bid like an american
citizen trying to make a bid
or a foreign national buying it out here
here's the
here's the uh inverse we saw in 2008
they were they were the government was
was saying you had to give out loans to
these families
families who often couldn't afford to
pay back these loans and then when the
loans went bad they tried stuffing them
into mortgage-backed securities trying
to find some way to make duds into
something valuable
and the whole system just broke apart a
lot of the criticism was well when the
government
forces people to lend to people who
clearly can't afford houses the housing
market explodes
well blackrock can certainly afford to
pay for these houses maybe these people
should be renters i suppose right
i certainly don't think so i think
people should have access to
homeownership
the difference here is it's the other
extreme coming in and telling a
middle-class person who can't afford the
house we're going to spend an extra 50
on top so you can't buy it is not the
same as mandating someone be given
special access to loans they can't
afford
i agree i i would like to i would like
to clarify this whole 2008 crisis a
little bit so they
they loaned out uh to citizens just
regular people they made loans to them
than the people
when they had trouble paying it back
because of what and inflation these
people there there
it was people with like uh and many
instances bad credit
had no had no business owning a home but
they were given these like no money down
loans with high interest rates
and then when the people couldn't pay
them back they started to default on the
loan and so they packaged the debt
into other things and then sold those to
like investment firms yep
there was something sinister going on
about the process because a lot of
people were kind of
a lot of people knew it was sort of a
racket and a lot of people were making
money and doing
a lot of bad things that hurt not just
the economy but the country so now the
world it's it sounds like they're using
that as an excuse to not
loan people money instead going the safe
route by just
loaning it to big corporations well i
suppose authoritarianism is always the
safe route i guess
right when you have despotic control of
a nation and you can oppress and strip
away the rights and
you know resources from the working
class so long as you have a good
psychological manipulation apparatus
which i guess we do sort of then uh you
got nothing to worry about definitely i
mean that's what we
that's what the press is i mean this is
what the press has been doing for
you know at least five years now yeah
it's amazing where it's like
you know journalism today is like make
the biggest lie
you know brian seltzer wow does that guy
lie like non-stop
and lick lick the feet of gensaki in
that horrible interview
that's what that's the media is this i
feel like we're about to transition our
government into like a more
democratically
decentralized system like a legit system
i've been studying the greek
the development of the greek democracy
500 600 bc
and basically the farmers the greek
farmers were paying a sixth
of their food to the to their local
landlords and they couldn't afford the
debt so they were putting their own
freedom up as collateral it used to be
legal to
you could say you can take my family as
a slave or me as a slave if i can't pay
back the debt
they couldn't pay back their debts or
they couldn't pay their taxes basically
so they were conscripted into slavery
and what was happening was
athens realized if they needed to call
up a military they couldn't because
these people were all unburdened by debt
so they were going to get taken over
from the outside because their people
were just wrecked
so they had to dispel all the debt all
that
1-6 they freed all the slaves i mean
they made drastic
changes to their system be out of
necessity because they were going to get
taken over by foreign power if they
didn't
we need to be able to rely on our
citizens to have strength willpower
and the ability to mobilize thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time